enfin
bonsoir messieurs dames van wyk
autant il était temps que ça rouvre h de
ça a été long et il tend et merci
à vous
attendent des rires entend des cris ça
faisait trop plaisir de voir des gens
l'euphorique on arrive à retrouver dans
leur bobine dans leur aux yeux dans leur
sourire leur état d'esprit d'avant
franchement
[Musique]
c'est le taulier entonnant 40 ans un cv
gaulé comme un festival peintres
photographes presque et dj et patrons
club surtout patrons de clubs voir ce
lieu tu peux dépérir enfin
vide
sans vie c'était c'était glauque moi je
venais je venais le moins possible et
le crève coeur c'était de bah ouais de
perdre le contact avec lui main de
l'artiste
voir cette scène revivre réaccueillir à
nouveau des artistes en loge
ça fait tellement de bien et puis
et puis on arrive à se dire que ouais on
ne s'est pas perdue c'est pas fini
alléluia c'est pas fini
avant l'entonnoir c'était ça des
milliers de clubbers des concepts par
dizaines des masques aussi mais pas les
mêmes juste pour rire aujourd'hui c'est
jauge réduite passe à la pâte mais c'est
toujours mieux que rien
même s'il a fallu se battre pour
continuer à danser le roi du bouc l'art
c'est fait porte étendard je suis pas du
genre je peux pas me taire quand j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya une injustice
qu'en plus elles ne me concernent au
début on n'avait pas des du tout donc
oui il ya un moment forcément je suis
pas content et on est quelques-uns pas
être content et puis on voyait pas
d'issue d'issue tout ça qu'il fallait
qu'on nous entende on va vous donner
l'occasion de mettre noir sur blanc
modeler ans si vous aviez en face de
vous le ou la président présidente
sur les 1500 discothèque qui restait au
début du coc vide en france il a quand
même plus de 400 cas confirmés et peut y
avoir une un besoin d'accompagnement
financier
sur une plus longue période que ça
jusqu'à jusqu'à ce que se passe
sanitaire disparaissent en fait c'est
simple nous on n'a plus une clientèle
alternative qui va du punk donc le punk
de lui demander de se faire vacciner ce
qu'impliquait le métalleux qui est en
général vegan équipait reproche nature
s'appliquer aussi leur coeur garage
harley davidson c'est pareil il a
tendance à lever le doigt en l'air c'est
ça qui m'inquiète le plus c'est combien
de temps va durer ce pass sanitaires et
combien de temps ces gens là vont être
récalcitrants ou combien de temps ils
vont jouer le jeu on a perdu une année
et demi de chiffre d'affaires je vous
laisse deviner on dépasse quand même le
million de chiffre d'affaires non
rentrée et puis on s'est endettée de
quelque chose qui fait de la hauteur du
bar de ce qu'on avait payé
l'établissement au départ il ya cette
épée de damoclès qui est au dessus de
nos têtes et donc le public à nous
répète notre clientèle on sera là
t'inquiète pas on sera là ouais mais si
par exemple pour
amortir toutes ses dettes qu'on va
contracter on est obligé d'augmenter un
tout petit peu notre bière de tarif
d'entrée est ce que toi tu vas suivre
sachant qu'en plus tout augmente et
retrouver la clientèle c'est pas gagné
trouver du personnel c'est pas gagné
rembourser les têtes c'est pas gagné il
est assez noir encore l'avenir
finalement il est n'est pas rose du tout
franchement il faut vite que ça reprenne
la bamboche la fête la vie la liberté
parce que franchement on en a vraiment
besoin
franchement